this is American Idol and this is Ryan
Seacrest reunited with his ex-girlfriend
Shana Taylor
yep the pair who dated for three years
before splitting earlier this year were
spotted together again here they are
enjoying lunch ah fresco during their
summer vacay and Positano Italy and I
witnessed lzt the duo laughed cuddled
and showed off some sweet PDA and this
excited et has been with Ryan throughout
the years at November he was excited to
spend some quality time with his
ladylove after jingle ball Shana here
tonight Shana is meeting me after for
late dinner her job was the plan what is
open after the show for us to eat yes
you know on a on a Friday night you got
it you got it fit it fit in the date
night on a Friday night too you know but
the TV host also said he didn't feel any
pressure to take their relationship to
the next level the family putting any
pressure on you you need to put a ring
on it
no here's the good news about my family
they're so distracted that my sister's
having a baby in about three days they
don't even know I exist yes it's true
after et learned of the couple split in
February we had to ask him the obvious
question on everyone's mind
do you ever be the bachelor I don't
think I'd be good at it no I don't think
so
I don't think I'd be good at remembering
all of the different things I have to
remind don't think I'd be great at it
but I might be the best I like watching
it I like watching it but yeah I think
I'm better as a spectator or maybe being
The Bachelor but who knows
[Music]
[Applause]